will the nation's report card is out and
it shows deep declines in math and a dip
in Reading good afternoon and thank you
so much for joining us here at four
o'clock I'm Christian Casitas this is
all a result of the pandemic's effects
on learning the math results were the
steepest declines ever recorded we take
a closer look at the numbers across the
nation and across Nevada as CCSD leaders
also weigh in on the results
naep the national assessment of
Education progress also known as the
nation's report card shows how students
are performing in both public and
private schools Across the Nation a
sample of fourth and 8th grade students
are assessed in both math and reading
about 9 300 students throughout our
state from 182 schools took these tests
nationally fourth grade students on
average scored three to five points
lower in math and reading when compared
to the 2019 test results 8th grade
students scored three to eight points
lower for math and reading as well in
Nevada 8th grade reading scores stayed
consistent from the 2019 test results
while 8th grade math scores dropped
about Five Points fourth grade students
in Nevada scored six to seven points
lower on math and reading tests when
compared to 2019 as for Clark County
Council of the great City Schools
executive director Ray Hart said in part
quote students have already returned to
the same performance levels observed
prior to the pandemic in eight grade
reading CCSD superintendent Dr Jesus
Jara says quote with this year's naep
data we see some encouraging results
however the reality is these numbers
serve as a roadmap for the Investments
we need to make with the remaining
coveted funding